llenó los espacios en blanco para
completar la ecuación 76 1830 es igual a
seis escenas de millares más un espacio
en blanco de millares más ocho centenas
más tres decenas vamos a reescribir esta
ecuación de esta manera escribimos con
código de colores 76 1830 esto es igual
a tener 70.000 más 6000 más 800 más 30
más 0 unidades lo que tenemos aquí es
casi lo mismo de lo que tenemos
planteado acá aunque hay algunas
diferencias tenemos cero unidades éste
no está no aparece acá tenemos 30 que es
lo mismo a tres decentes es igual
tenemos 800 que es lo mismo que 8
centenas y aquí ya empiezan a ver las
diferencias
aquí tenemos millares y aquí tenemos 6
millones entonces este es el que tenemos
que empezar a calcular y también tenemos
la diferencia en las decenas de millares
aquí está
70 mil o 7 decenas de millares y aquí
hay seis decenas de millares
esencialmente quitaron una decena de
millas de aquí y la pusieron en otro
lugar seguramente lo pusieron aquí con
los millares entonces aquí para dejarlo
igual a cómo está el planteamiento vamos
a quitar una decena de millar de manera
que nos queda aquí 60 mil y esta decena
la vamos a poner aquí en los millares
nos va a quedar 16.000 ó 16 millares y
hacemos lo mismo de este lado aquí este
7 se transforma en un 6 y este 6 se
transforma en un 16 y ahora si lo que
escribimos aquí luce igual a lo que
tenemos en el planteamiento del problema
el espacio en blanco es de 16 millones